that was a
crazy fight
no you said x twice
i don't have anything to heal
i have nothing in our items to heal
[Music]
get on the second level
we not have any heal items
we have one there is no it's
it's not an option in the inventory you
could sort what your healing stuff
yeah it's under
maybe nothing to me
maybe we don't share stuff up yeah
look at me
let me drop this
oh no it went away you dropped it
yeah it disappeared wow so you can't
even pick it back up yourself
no that's fine so we can't technically
trade items
like that what does your inventory look
like is it just like some guns and stuff
his guns what's the first thing in your
inventory
it's um with your warrior assault right
yeah we have the same inventory
but when i go to usable items you said
you had something
and mine oh now i see it
wait it was it yeah i see now i see
first aid kit
that's weird so you have to like you
can't
quit move that you can equipped it you
can equip
it it's just a quick okay
what it what now if i equip it for him
my god
it's not equipped for her you have to
put on
see both her this is so weird for her
she doesn't have
like it's grayed out yeah because one of
them already has it
they're counting one as two people see
look if you look at it it's grayed out
because you don't
fit the requirements to use it
so she don't fit the requirement to use
first aid like i
you have to have level one in first aid
and i bet you she doesn't you probably
don't
wow
damn
[Music]
i'm just i got new perks that's what i'm
just doing something
all right
oh yeah i gotta switch that gun bro that
joint that's not it
background
after we do this level um we'll probably
call it a knife
that's cool
it's my back starting to give out okay
you ain't got your [ __ ] perks oh
oh i got a perk nice good
i think fire keep okay
get their heads down give your body a
chance to
how good is suppressing in this game
oh armor plus two healthy
i love one of these
armor up
yeah this wasn't feeling oppression
oh you gotta level that flavor up
that's level two
oh you'll do anything for the team if
any of them goes down
this is good you do it if one of them
goes down you leave it to actually i
think that
one 1.1 combat speed
two turns an ally is down
in battle emergency response
yeah let me just change over that thing
all right so this is right
i'm shocking them
that's a better one
oh
i'm gonna use
all right i'm ready
get back coming out
and they threw people in the pit
they was out here frame boiling
damn
oh they threw her family in there
[Music]
they had to barbecue for real
damn girl i don't know if they're here
or not
i can't come on
let's find the monsters who did this
watch it let's see if we can find her
family in the barbecue
child sized coffee clutches take the
bottle yet
that that was one of the schuyler girls
i think seems like we ought to leave her
alone
feels an awful lot like grave robbing
take the bundle
listen man book
do i have to equip that like last time
switch yeah let me equip that because i
don't want to be in the heat of the
battle with the giant
you might want to see if you can use one
of them right now
it's our health low how do i see her
health it's at the bottom left
oh yeah sure it is
yeah thank you shoot slow
yeah my man need to doing too good
either
[Music]
what's the underneath the health what's
the second one what's the second blue
bar
um i don't see a second bar
for me it says khan and then it says oh
i guess it's experience okay that's
experience okay
i got it that's right
on behalf of all of us here i want to
offer our unconditional surrender
as proof of our good will i want to tell
you that the culprits got into town with
help from farron brago's organization
and
isaac how could you how could you throw
in with these people how could you let
them take my family
where are my parents and my little
brother they're
they're in the grave you passed on the
way here they didn't suffer
lucia i promise baby look
i didn't mean it to go this way i tried
to stop them
stop talking right now
your kids are helping us hurt these
pieces together you know
yeah we gotta ghetto we gotta get him
not forgiveness we want to face justice
we know what we it was amelia's dorsey
he went looking for your family lucia
your family especially
that's why i got you out of your house
before the raid oh
i didn't want anything to happen to you
what you didn't want anything to happen
to me
so you let savages abduct and murder my
family
you knew what they meant to me you knew
what their loss would do to me
but you're still alive lucia don't you
see
you're still alive and that's what
matters most to me oh god wow
this is spooky
we've been under the patriarchs boot for
50 years
we say that the hundred families are in
charge but it's really just his family
just him i know you must think i'm a
fuzzy-headed idealist but
this society's sick it needs to change
fair and brygo's gang helped them get
into town
i don't know how or why and i overheard
nelius say something about liberty
buchanan
the patriarch's daughter i think that
person
i think she's going to attack colorado
springs
it sounded like she's gathering an army
out in the plains
something way worse than the dorsey's
he escaped he took some vehicles and
headed west into the mountains
i don't think he was planning to come
back i have heard enough
if your betrayal of my family was not
sufficient
your treachery here most certainly is
in the name of the patriarch i
sentence you please lucia i did this for
you
all i ever meant was to help build a
better world for you
for all of us i can't tell you how much
i regret
please don't kill me please
what you gonna do
please lucia i love you
all we gotta make an example
it's going to take him a long time to
die
yo yo they finish the job
yo let it kill isaac
finish the job kid you want to take a
life take it
oh my god
he doesn't deserve anybody
kill isaac oh for her oh
like i can do it oh okay it did
let's get ruthless
okay all right
she breathed
oh you got lit oh they all just popped
up cause we
ah what they do
y'all
[Music]
get it
[Music]
i like her billy's precision straight
white
you level her up and she's accurate
oh it's out of breathe that's what it is
okay i
[Music]
how many snapshots she got
man always
[Music]
you know you know what i gotta do right
beat him up the fist you
found out
[Music]
some of them have guns
oh
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
but the question is is there percentages
on the miss
[Music]
oh my god
this is ranger hq we're getting reports
of shooting in your last known location
at garden of the gods
what's your status i'm gonna say there's
no survivors
yes we killed everybody story's right in
the hundred family kids helping them
yeah that's what we did
roger that november one maybe let's not
talk too loudly about this killing
hundred pounds
over and out hey
so the dude the picture i think i'll be
happy with that
oh
now the 100 family they might care
let's just not tell them
all right before we let's go back to the
town before we uh because there's
nothing else here
i want to show you what the uh the uh
the hub world looks like
and then once i show you something in
the hub world then we'll call it
[Music]
it really do not be feeling like this is
on my ssd
this does not feel like any vietnamese
premium experience
you let me shoot him never shut
anybody before you want to freak out my
boyfriend
i mean my ex-boyfriend i
killed him i really killed him
absolutely you can't believe his life
dad i can't what do we do out here isn't
that what you're in there what you did
what the hell is wrong with you i i
i did but was this it
was isaac who i should have shot i do
your
family in a barbie i need to find the
people who steered isaac wrong
the people who were really responsible
nelius dorsey and liberty buchanan
will you help me find them you can count
on my guns every step of the way
good we'll help you return you follow
orders
now what do you think once of course
liberty
because she's awesome kill this she got
yourselves a bargain rangers bring her
back alive
we should go after kneeling i promise
that preacher
isaac said he headed west into the
mountains
left behind the expendables in the
garden
i thought she said she was gonna follow
orders not
give for now we should head back to the
sheriff
how's the family shut your home
i'm gonna have to disarm that thing's
really coming again huh
there's always something breaking
you have to follow me oh i thought i was
following you
no it was
[Music]
just wait till you see this helpful this
this
oh i'm controlling it
you killed my brother jared remember
me kill a bunch of innocent folk cause
you was too
chicken to save them got a whole family
trapped in their homestead
about three generations worth now if you
don't want them to be the next to die in
the day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
receiving an urgent distress call in
your area this is arapahoe 44.
we're pinned down on 25 south of
colorado spri
44 are you there 44.
lost contact you heard them november and
listen
this isn't just any convoy a44 is
hauling new power armor for the marshals
near call but would advise against
taking your time november
that cargo is absolutely essential to
colorado springs this is where the
patriarchy
over and out don't worry about that open
shop
there we go
does it let you give me control
that's what i was i would love to do if
i could do that it just says radio
and map
you entered a vibrant rain something
makes you slow the caught up moving the
noise
trust your injuries go cautiously what
do you want to do
i don't see the options
this is showing fear forward trust your
instincts and go cautiously
that's only two yeah try that
oh i own the conversation man okay
you gave it to me no yeah i think you
ordered that
well i'm an idiot
oh that's uh all right
light them up wow
and i thought colorado trash was sad you
made a bad deal rangers
my father's using you for cannon fodder
go back to arizona before you take a
bullet for him
the graves are cold up here and on your
way home
tell him to hire a better class of spy
why would your father know your father
put your hands up
now keep in mind keep in mind
we don't want to smoke i'm just going to
be real with you
got some cool bloody [ __ ] taking you out
here
don't just say your father george you
put your hands up
points for bravado but my robots will
turn you into a thin red mist before you
get a shot off
want to reconsider
[Music]
thank you for your permission squad
roll out
you're the fact that they got a sucker
answer
good writing that's good you said that
we good we good we're good you know what
you go on with yourself
i like to think about the soccer ball
oh can't transfer conversation other
players too far away
okay
try to drop through the jewels you might
not make you might make it like that
before officially you're free okay
i'm not going the right way can you
press start
okay safe yeah
i will continue our adventures